today a sad message
myrthe green from the grounds
You also know her through my flip-flop
I have done a lot with sara
the mother of myrthe
he died last Wednesday
it all went very peacefully
the parents have it on their own socials
also announced on instagram
what people don't know is that
that
it is of course also financially
something means for the family
the wlz that falls away
the car has just stopped
the funeral is of course always a cost item
where you are not
take that kind of thing into account
so I'm on behalf of
started a crowdfunding for them too
following a live one that I did yesterday
what people said they liked that too
so I started that now
and if you say so
I also want the vegetables
allow a little rest in the first coming period
and help you on your way
just follow the link in my bio and make a donation
and just think all the little bits and help
welcome
calm dear myrtle